[Music]
kathy's biggest etf has returned well in
excess of 100
kathy wood has had a very strong year
where she is one of the world's leading
investors in innovation and disruption
in the public equity markets
this is kathy wood she runs arkhanvest a
wall street firm that invests people's
money into disruptive fields like ai
robotics gene editing and more with over
billion dollars under her management
well to be
honest we're up to 50 billion now and
this is what she had to say about the
price of tesla stock back in 2018
which we think could take the stock get
ready uh
to four thousand dollars four thousand
four thousand dollars if we're right the
bull case
at the time everyone thought she was
crazy and she got a lot of hate for her
prediction
and yet on january 7 2021 tesla hit that
four thousand dollar mark a whole two
years ahead of her prediction
when you account for the five to one
stock split that happened shortly before
on top of that kathy saw selling the
best returns in the history of money
management in 2020.
you're having one of the best years in
the history
of professional money management
catapulting her into one of the most
talked about celebrities in the
investment world
but that brings up the question the
stock market had an insane year in
general after that initial crash at the
start of 2020.
so is kathy what the next warren buffet
of disruptive tech
or just lucky if you look at her
portfolio it's not really uh any more
interesting than the average 12 year
old's portfolio so
my stance on it is that all she's really
done
is invested into the same stocks that
everyone else invested in
and oddly enough if you go on wall
street bets you could probably find
hundreds of people who
made uh 10 times the return that she's
made simply by
putting stock options on those same bets
like on tesla
and um all she's really doing is
bundling it up
and charging a fee for it one of warren
buffett's most fundamental investing
rules is simple
invest in what you understand or in
other words invest in your circle of
competence
throwing money at ai robotics and gene
editing stocks is cool and all
but if you don't know anything about
those fields you're basically gambling
that's where brilliant.org comes in
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and app that teaches you to think like
an engineer in bite-size
hands-on interactive lessons if you're
watching this video you're obviously
interested in investing in business
so what i love about brilliant is that
it lets you get a great foundational
understanding
of all these different fields all in one
place they have courses on artificial
neural networks quantum computing
gravitational physics for space
exploration
and courses for a lot of the other
fields we're going to cover in this
video
and if you visit brilliant.org jake tran
or click the link in the description you
can sign up for free
and the first 200 people that go to that
link will get 20 off the annual premium
subscription
that's brilliant.org jake tran with the
link in the video description
kathy's meteor career started with a
degree in finance and economics at the
university of southern california in
1981.
she studied under a popular economist
named dr art laffer
who was known for the laffer curve she
started as an assistant economist at
another asset management firm
then spent the next 40 years climbing
the ranks of high finance
eventually managing over 5 billion
dollars in assets as the chief
investment officer at alliance bernstein
then comes the tech bubble of the 90s to
early 2000s
the new economy is it a boom without end
investors were dumping money into what
they thought were disruptive fews that
just weren't ready for prime time yet
it was too early according to kathy so
investors lost a ton of money during
that era and a ton
more during the 2008 crisis so what did
they do
everyone started pouring money into
other investments that they perceived to
be safer
like index funds and passive investing
and by pouring into these safer
investments
disruptive sectors that are perceived to
be riskier haven't been getting as much
attention
and it created an opportunity what kathy
refers to as value traps
because what has happened since the
tekken telecom crash
and the 0809 meltdown there's been a
shift to what
what investors perceive is safety so
there's been a lot of indexing and
passive investing
guess what they are in harm's way
because those
indexes are filling up with value traps
if we're right growth investors are
holding right now a bunch of value traps
because the world that we are in is
moving so blazingly fast
so in 2014 she registered the arc
investment management llc with the sec
and this is her master plan kathy's
entire investment strategy centers
around throwing money into what she
calls innovation platforms
very jargony term i know but innovation
platforms have three main
characteristics
number one costs start high but as more
of the product is produced
the price goes down until it reaches a
point of critical mass where a ton of
people can all of a sudden afford
something like an airplane ticket
and demand explodes where price is
rapidly dropping number two these
innovation platforms cut across the
economy different sectors and spread
across the world
like electricity and number three they
end up helping people create even more
innovation
like all the ideas and businesses that
have sprang up thanks to the one
invention of the internet
the last giant technological revolution
man experience was back in the late
1800s to early 1900s
this was when huge inventions or
innovation platforms like the telephone
internal combustion engine and
electricity all converge around the same
period
and the result an explosion of economic
activity
or in other words there was a ton of
wealth to be made during that period
today kathy argues that humanity is at
another critical juncture in time
another period where massive innovation
platforms are once again
all converging together and the result
is going to be the biggest
fastest period of growth humanity has
ever seen
and these are the areas she's investing
in for arc which have done quite well so
far
her company's most popular products are
their actively managed etfs
basically you can buy these arc etfs
like any other stock
and they pull everyone's money together
to buy a bunch of stocks that they think
are the most innovative
think gene editing robotics batteries
artificial intelligence blockchain and
coming up
space exploration stocks all the
innovation platforms kathy thinks are on
the verge of convergence like we just
talked about
and so far she's done extremely well
with their main arc innovation etf up 45
in the last five years compared to the s
p 500 which was up only 15
and she has some insane projections for
the future for the next five years we
believe
our uh returns will compound at an
annual rate of
something in the low 20 range which are
still very optimistic
with the vision of solving the world's
biggest problems through allocating
capital
allocating capital to its highest and
best use in terms of
increasing access uh solving the world's
problems
um there can't be anything more
satisfying but
if you watch this channel you know that
there are always two sides to what
people say
and their potential motive and there's
one big problem that people like arvid
ali see with people like kathy
he's the president of jordan belford's
companies and runs one of the most
successful consulting firms in silicon
valley
the fact that some person is running
around
doing pr about their returns
simply by investing into tesla like
every other human being
i don't really understand why people
would just give their money to somebody
who also invested in the same crop that
you know everyone else invested i don't
really see um
how she's done anything distinct per se
she's not found a single company that
no one else has found she's just saying
like hey guys
i agree with you let's all invest into
these hyped-up
companies and uh just trust me and i'll
invest in the companies that you'd want
to invest in anyway um and let me
collect
uh let me collect five ten times times
the
the fees then that a standard uh
passively managed etf
would charge the main critique of kathy
is that it's one thing to open up a
hedge fund or a vc firm and offer rich
people access to private investments
that they wouldn't normally be able to
invest in
but public companies companies that you
and i can buy right now on our favorite
stock trading app
and promoting your revolutionary
investment to not sophisticated
investors who wouldn't be able to see
past you like sophisticated rich people
could
so here's a big difference is like with
a lot of let's say in private equity
the idea even in venture capital despite
the fact that i consider a ponzi scheme
at least there's some sense
in saying that like hey i'm going to put
your money into these hot
private tech startups that you wouldn't
ever be able to access oh that's the
truth yeah um here it's like why don't i
just
go on robinhood and invest the same
companies and like the outperformer
so what is kathy's secret according to
people like arvid well
like the founder of vanguard says the
behemoth company was 6.2 trillion
dollars under management
so it's a great big marketing business
but with more innovation evolving than
ever before how are investors supposed
to identify the technologies that could
deliver
future growth step number one you want
to inspire people by tapping into that
religious sacred aspect of their
psychology
the part of them that longs for more
that longs for purpose that gets
inspired by the idea of the future
space travel curing cancer solving human
suffering with a god complex
like people who have lost religion so
they're looking for meaning in some kind
of end of history that you're not just
giving me your money for the sake of
growing your money
but that you're participating in
something bigger than yourself that's
gonna help the world
saying we're gonna save the world
together participate in the next tech
revolution
and you're gonna make a ton of money in
the process is a much easier sell than
just saying i'm gonna make money for you
if you invest with me
and new ways of looking at the world
helping people understand
you know how the world's going to change
and
not only in their investment portfolios
but also
in their own lives their children's
lives their grandchildren's lives
helping them understand how to move
everyone to the right side of change
and really benefit from the exponential
growth trajectories that are just taking
off now
step number two invest in over-hyped
companies that anyone else can buy so
you kinda just ride the wave
there's a few things so one is she
doesn't know anything about technology
based on her background there's a single
point of indication that she understands
the first thing about any piece of
technology
pretty much every piece of jargon that
she says is typically memorized
from a handful of people that i
personally know we quantify multi-year
value chain transformations
and market opportunities to identify
entry points for tech-enabled disruption
so that investors can stay on the right
side of change
then she also points to her analysts
being
industry insiders in all these different
industries again i looked at
all their linkedin profiles they have
about as much expertise in any of these
technologies as the average reddit user
so
um i don't really see how she has any
you know particular insight that no one
else has
step number three collect huge fees
compared to other passively managed etfs
her ats for example all charge around a
0.75
expense ratio which may not sound like
much but many passively managed etfs
charge as low as 0.03 percent per year
or 25 times less than kathy's meaning
that with 50 billion under management
assuming all of that 50 billion is under
a 0.75
expense ratio which it isn't some
products are higher and somewhere lower
but assuming that's true that comes out
to around 375 million per year
and all that money is coming out of the
pockets from average every day people
that could have easily bought the same
stocks on their own
without paying any management fees for
these videos and interviews i really
do try to understand the other side of
the argument don't people like kathy ha
serve a purpose like if i were to want
to invest in like space
she's about to launch a space etf
doesn't a person like kathy provide
serve a purpose like if i wanted to
easily invest in like space companies
yeah i mean you can also just google the
same space companies and end up
investing those same companies without
paying her
the fees so if you look at the history
of
all actively managed etfs so to speak
meaning like
etfs that try to use the strategy of
just constantly trading
stocks in uh in trent the industries
they have historically completely failed
um the reason they get really popular is
because again they're trying to take
advantage of a trend
and they try to get as many people's
money as they quickly can and as soon as
they um get everyone's money they
collect as many fees as they can
and very quickly the performance of that
etf uh largely under performs the rest
of the market so
typically you'll see like a big uh big
wave up and a big wave down and even if
that isn't the case in her
in her situation again i don't really
see how her stock portfolio is any
better than the average
12 year olds in fact this is nothing new
and it's kind of like what wall street
was doing during the
common telecom bubble of the 90s i will
say that she's actually very bright
she's a very bright human being for uh
what she's doing which is that
she noticed that there is a phenomenon
that's very similar to what happened in
the 1990s it's just a new generation so
they haven't
experienced what happened in the 90s but
the same psychology
around innovation so to speak uh
created that massive bubble that existed
in the 90s and effectively same things
happening again and she's like oh great
it's a new generation they haven't lived
through the 90s
and because they haven't experienced
that they're naive to this and now
you know we can play out that same game
again but to really understand what's
going on here
you have to understand the business
model of wall street you're the
president of jordan belfort
in the movie the wolf of wall street uh
one of the best scenes in my opinion was
jordan's first lunch meeting with his
first boss
matthew mcconaughey where he explains uh
the entire business is uh you want to
take the money from their pocket and put
it into your pocket
name of the game move the money from
your client's pocket
into your pocket so that's literally how
it is
that wasn't an example in a nutshell
yeah there's nothing more
to it it's that but if you can make a
client's money at the same time it's
advantageous to everyone
correct no there's
it's like there's no there's no more
like um
thinking to it and the reason they make
everything so complicated in terms of
its terminology in terms of getting
licensed all this nonsense is
to make it more and more confusing about
the simple fact that they're just
they're just there to take people's
money wall street exclusively exists
more or less
uh to steal people's money for anyone
who thinks otherwise they don't really
understand how wall street works
quite frankly most of the analysts in
wall street don't actually understand
this pretty much only the executives
fully
comprehend this so the point of wall
street
is to take as many people's hard-earned
money as you can
without them noticing is the idea
however the most important thing you
have to understand about this business
model
is that you cannot screw over rich
people because rich people will one
see right through you and two they'll
fight back and destroy you
as we're seeing happening right now
before our eyes video coming soon
subscribe so you don't miss out
so you want to make sure you only target
plebs that are more uneducated
um the only people who have ever gone to
jail who have come out of wall street
are the people who made a mistake of
taking money from rich people
instead of regular people so for anyone
who thinks that something you know
uh something positive is happening to
the world because wall street exists
they don't really understand how
how that industry operates but then
again we can't recap his mind we'd never
met her before
so this is all speculation and here's
her rationale for her business
i felt that the right thing to do was go
where no one was
and i've had good success over the years
doing that if you see everyone moving in
one direction and sure hedge funds have
been
so lucrative for asset managers
but if you see everyone moving into
hedge funds and private
and you look at a a new rapper that's
actually a good deal for the end
investor
and you go with low cost and public
using the private market valuations as
an umbrella
maybe just maybe you'll be on to
something big
so what's the verdict on kathy wood on
one hand the argument against her and
wall street in general makes
complete sense on the other hand she
does come off pretty genuine if you
watch her interviews
she does seem pretty passionate about
what she does and she's even mentioned
that she doesn't expect these giant
gains to last forever
and whenever things have gone this well
for me uh usually there's a correction
around the bend i do want to warn
investors that you know in the
investment world
it's not just straight up and to the
right you know we will have those
corrections
and if you are just really lazy and you
want to invest in these innovative
fields in the most hands-off way
possible
and you know you're getting screwed on
fees for stocks you can easily buy on
your own
and you're okay with that well who am i
to stop you
but i will leave it at this with a quote
that one of my favorite thinkers nascene
nicholas telep references
trading may have princess but nobody
stays king the people you meet on the
way up
you will meet again on the way down
if you're interested in the world of
investing trading you really like the
movie the big short
why not check this out this is a course
going over the math use and quantitative
finance
the same kind of math the pros on wall
street use with the promise being that
by the end of this course you'll have
all the skills needed to ace any
quantitative finance interview
that's my quant your what my
quantitative
my math specialist look at him you
notice anything different about him look
at his face
it's got 26 interactive lessons going
over 200 plus concepts and exercises on
everything from quant finance to
variants to markov chains and more
and once you're done with that course
you'll have plenty of other courses to
check out on finance
and all the other tech fields we went
over and who knows maybe one day you'll
launch your own investment fund
just don't forget to give me a cut of
the profits as warren buffett says
the best investment you can make is an
investment in yourself so if you want to
check out that quantitative finance
course
join over 8 million people learning on
brilliant by going to brilliant.org
jake trent to sign up for free and the
first 200 people that go to that link
will get 20
off the annual premium subscription
that's brilliant.org
jake tran with the link in the video
description
so what do you guys think of kathy wood
are you invested in her etfs should tran
capital launch our own etfs let me know
in the comments below
arvid the guy you've seen sprinkled
throughout this video super sharp guy
the president of jordan belfort's
companies and a whole list of other
accolades that make him a very
impressive individual
he's building his own channel where he's
revealing a lot more of the world's like
inside information as you can tell by
the name
super good stuff stuff that you're not
going to hear about anywhere else and
you can check it out with the link in
the video description
if you guys want to watch the entire
interview i did with arvid you guys can
check out our new channel
intellectual dropouts where we have
dangerous conversations for dangerous
minds like yourself
and if you're curious about the meaning
behind the name my rationale for it is
that you don't have
to be in academia you don't have to have
a college degree you don't have to be in
college
to be passionate and curious about stuff
like business geopolitics philosophy
in fact everyone should be interested in
this stuff so that is what we're going
to disseminate
on the new channel which you guys can
check out and subscribe to with the link
below
that is all i have for this video today
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous out there as always and
i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you